thank you for having these coasters here
I need something
I don't know what it is I don't know
what I match your watch they do it does
you know what those are yours if you
want them really yeah no and then we
charge you
all right it's like a robe at a hotel
saying those are yours it's a very fine
line it is weird that I do when I come
to do your podcast that I have to leave
a credit card for incidental
that is weird but 2K a piece yeah so you
know we should start doing leather just
for fun and for profit but we have like
a nice coffee machine in our offices and
everything just but then if when when
people left if their publicist got a
little thing it just said like yeah Nick
had get a coffee so that's 12. Nick we
saw Nick had a Starbucks and then
there's the little Junior Mints
um so Nick use the bathroom yeah so
that's yeah and there's a lot of Water
Crisis and there's also a resort fee and
a convenience charge for coming in
there's a mic charge there's the mic
charge and uh Conan made eye contact
with you so that's another thing
you get it you get six thousand dollars
you've got some cash
I think we've covered it all I mean
we've done it all like Bogan McCall you
know is that a thing I just said it
sounded real yeah they did it all like
Bogey and Bacall were they were they a
thing like uh Catherine Hepburn and
Spencer Tracy I thought there were
differences I suppose but uh well
they're all basically the same person
right sure yeah as I understand they
were they were they were black and white
in real life yeah and they talked like
that she I'm gonna kiss you yeah you're
gonna kiss me right now yeah they're
gonna have sex see yeah sex yeah that's
how everyone
that's that was Pillow Talk in the 1930s
if you want to again get it get a little
taste of that go see Paul Newman and uh
James Dean wow yeah do you think really
you think they were there was a sexual
chemistry I'm telling you there is Vibe
watch that clip there is a Vibe I'll
tell you this and it comes out in the
documentary that uh tragic but
um James Dean was getting all the parts
and then and um
Paul Newman was perennial was The
Perennial also ran and then uh the
moment that James Dean died uh Paul
Newman starts getting the roles so that
was one of those well no no he wasn't
Wiley Coyote interesting pretending
switching the signs around to catch
Newman's Own anvils
James Dean
famously killed by an anvil they hit him
seconds before he crashed but all Frozen
still go to charity yeah yeah I love
that
Newman's Own rocket shoes all proceeds
go to charity
kids playing in a camp yay thank you Mr
Newman
do its own bats yeah
[Laughter]
just the crime scene at the g at the
James Dean's crash oh there's salad
dressing all over the world
a guy leaning over and putting his
finger in it and tasting it yeah hmm
that's a vinaigrette that's a Newman's
Own vinaigrette
popcorn in the toe pipe okay all right
listen you know what I mean what you've
done basically now is you've accused
Paul Newman of murdering James Dean and
I won't have it not on the podcast not
on any podcast I can't do it on any
other podcast
okay the murder ones would love it all
right well what about uh Kona needs an
enemy can we cover that yeah episode 32.
we're back at the observatory where
there's a statue of James Dean
I just do very La specific jokes for you
guys this that's the way to end right on
that joke I think so if you're ever
gonna get out I think that's the one
[Laughter]
that's always get out on something kind
of okay can I talk about just quickly
promote the movie get out yeah it's
great movie Jordan peel made it yeah
about seven years ago seven eight years
ago eight nine eight eight nine years a
game changing film hey quick should I
get a plug out there for penicillin
uh invented uh by Fleming in the early
40s but really Ian Fleming yeah
but no uh ree it's fantastic wonder drug
yeah and and overused overused and now
of course we see and antibiotic
resistance
this is where you get out oh man yeah uh
can you put huge laughs on antibiotic
resistance now no oh sorry how about a
breakouts cricket sounds no I'm uh part
of the podcast Brotherhood of producers
I'm not allowed to no no
can't fake an ending are you kidding
and that's where we got antibiotic
resistance
so a lot of wind is coming yeah yeah I
jumped out I jumped I had my Newman's
Own bat suit on and I jumped off a cliff
to catch the roadrunner